and it's a pleasure for me to introduce
Professor Arthur McDonald he was born in
in Sydney Nova Scotia Canada in in 1943
he studied at Dalhousie University in
Nova Scotia and then at the California
Institute of Technology in the US where
he became a doctor in 1969 he worked at
the chalk river nuclear laboratories and
in 1982 and then it became professor
first at Princeton University and then
later at Queen's University Kingston
Canada and is presently director of the
Sudbury neutrino Observatory scientific
collaboration so please professor
McDonough
thank you this is a great honor for me
and my colleagues too and we would like
to thank the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences and the Nobel foundation for
this tremendous honor it's also an honor
to share this prize with Professor K
jitta and the members of the
super-kamiokande collaboration for the
beautiful work that you just saw so I'm
going to tell a slightly different story
a story that was happening in parallel
with the one you just heard and one
which was attempting to address
neutrinos had come from the Sun a case
where it had been a possibility that the
explanation for what had come to be
known as the solar neutrino problem was
due to flavor change for neutrinos in
this case electron neutrinos produced in
the core of the Sun and so I'm going to
tell you about how that was done with
the Sudbury neutrino Observatory which
is actually represented in reality here
this is a picture taken looking up from
the bottom of the sphere surrounded by
light sensors in much the same way that
light sensors were used in the
super-kamiokande experiment so neutrinos
you've heard about their properties they
can penetrate through almost anything
they're a wonderful way to study what's
happening directly in the core of the
Sun eight minutes ago they travel almost
at the speed of light they're produced
prolifically by the fusion reactions
that are powering the Sun and they reach
us here on earth and they can even
penetrate through to our detectors which
in our case were situated two kilometers
underground the story of the Sun is a
long one and this phrase that we stand
on the shoulders of giants is something
that is very true in this case
it's Hans bethe and William Fowler who
was the head of the laboratory in which
I studied at Caltech in 1969 have
developed the understanding of how the
nuclear reactions power the Sun and Ray
Davis and John Bacall were pioneers in
the study of neutrino oscillatory knows
from the Sun Ray Davis with his chlorine
based detector who observed that the
number of neutrinos that he measured
were about three times smaller than what
was calculated by very sophisticated
calculations that John Bacall and
collaborators carried out Bruno
Pontecorvo was mentioned earlier and
along with the Japanese collaborators
who put forward the what we these these
days refer to as the EM NSP approach to
understanding the three flavor
oscillations at the time that the
deficit was observed by Ray Davis
Pontecorvo & grebe off suggested that
perhaps the explanation for why too few
neutrinos were being observed was that
electron neutrinos had been changing
into muon neutrinos in transit from the
core of the Sun at that point of course
the knowledge of three neutrino types
was was not present and that has was
expanded later to the thought that it
was the possibility of oscillation in
either of the other two types the actual
reactions that are occurring in the Sun
that produce the neutrinos you can see
the neutrinos circled in red here are as
shown here this is what the energy
release in the process is shown here are
what produces the power in the Sun in
1984 the start of the snow collaboration
occurred because herb Chen asked whether
it's conceivable to obtain enough heavy
water from Canada's reserves to perhaps
do an experiment in Canada using that
heavy water there was a wonderful
correspondence with George Ewan who's
here with us today who had been looking
for the opportunity to do underground
science in Canada and had identified an
ideal location which was provided to us
by the International nickel company in
Sudbury Ontario a very deep location and
the idea that herb put forward was that
if you studied some of these are the
highest or close to the highest energy
neutrinos produced if you had enough
heavy water you could conceivably make a
measurement in which you could not only
observe the type of neutrinos that were
being produced in the core of the Sun
but also observe the sum of all other
neutrino types and so a direct
comparison of those two things would
tell you whether it whether you act on
neutrinos were changing into the other
types without recourse to calculations
of how many were being produced in the
core of the Sun and so in 1984 a
collaboration came together
this shows the collaboration picture at
chalk river in 1986 and it also at the
bottom shows a paper that was published
at this at that time putting the concept
forward the spokespersons at that point
were herb Chen for the United States
George Ewan for Canada they were joined
about a year later when the UK joined
the experiment as led by Dave Sinclair
and we started attempting to develop
this experiment unfortunately about six
months after this picture was taken
herb Chen passed away from leukemia much
too early an age and we we still miss
him and regard him as a substantial
origin of this
experimental collaboration after herb
passed away I took over as the u.s.
spokesperson for the project and in 1989
became the director of the project as we
were all working very hard to put
together this experiment in the meantime
we had been joined by more groups in the
United States and and Britain and we had
a more substantial collaboration at the
time that we were funded in 1990 so how
did we detect neutrinos from the Sun
well those billions that are streaming
out from the from the Sun require a
large amount of material in order to
obtain enough interactions to get
statistical accuracy on the numbers that
are in fact being observed both in the
category of electron neutrinos and other
types and so we needed a big detector we
also needed rather the properties of
this rather unique material heavy water
about one in 6,400 molecules of ordinary
water that you drink have an extra
Neutron in the nucleus in the hydrogen
nucleus making it deuterium or d2o
rather than h2o and we were able to
borrow a thousand tons of this material
and that's what we used as the basis for
our detector if you have that material
then there are some specific reactions
that you can observe in all cases using
the same Cherenkov radiation as was
described to you earlier for the
super-kamiokande experiment and using
light sensors surrounding this tank of
heavy water the first one is very
specific to electron neutrinos we call
it the charged current reaction and I
will refer to CC later on as a monadic
for this particular reaction sensitive
only two electron neutrinos in this case
a deuterium of course has a neutron and
a proton in it as you can see here one
of those neutrons has changed into a pro
and a fast-moving electron that produces
trunk off light in your detector the
second reaction which is a unique one
for deuterium is one in which any
neutrino type with equal sensitivity
electron Muir Tao can break deuterium
apart giving you a free Neutron we used
three different techniques to detect
those neutrons in different phases of
the project and that particular case is
only sensitive to well it's sensitive
all neutrino types and so if you compare
these two then you're able to tell if
the number of electron neutrinos is the
same as the total in which case nothing
will have happened but as we eventually
observed we only saw one third as many
electron neutrinos as the total
demonstrating that neutrinos had changed
their type you have to be very careful
when you're trying to do this
measurement because it is possible for
radioactivity particularly gamma rays to
break deuterium apart producing a free
Neutron
and so we had to control radioactivity
extremely carefully in order to be sure
that we were not seeing a false signal
from that radioactivity and therefore we
went to great lengths to control
radioactivity in our experiment there is
another reaction in which the neutrinos
strike electrons and this is in fact
something that super-kamiokande also
used to look at solar neutrinos it has
predominantly a sensitivity to electron
neutrinos but it has a small sensitivity
also to all neutrino types and in fact
before our full result using the first
two reactions we combined our data with
data from super-kamiokande and had a
preliminary indication that neutrinos
from the Sun were in fact oscillating
the three techniques were used for
detecting the neutrons are a little
complicated technically but basically in
the first phase of the project we simply
looked at a particular gamma ray that's
produced when that Neutron is captured
by the by the deuterium in the detector
that gamma ray is distinctive we later
put several tons of ordinary table salt
in the heavy water and that increased
the efficiency for detecting that
Neutron by a significant amount and also
created a situation where we could by
looking at the distribution of the event
on our photos sensors we could tell the
difference between this case where there
were many gamma rays being emitted and
therefore it was quite uniform or
isotropic compared to that very specific
trunk off ring for the case where we're
dealing with just electron neutrinos and
then finally we put 400 meters of ultra
low radioactivity proportional counters
that had helium-3 in them and detected
neutrons directly and that I'll show you
a picture later was the third phase of
the experiment with a separate
measurement entirely of those neutrons
so what did this detector look like well
first of all it was about the size of a
10-story building it was 2 kilometers
underground in a very active nickel mine
one of incas most productive mines and
it continues to be to this day owned by
the valet company we had that thousand
tons of heavy water that was about 300
million dollars worth loaned to us for
$1 for 10 years that's pretty good
leverage in any market and Canadian
government agency that loaned it to us
was really one of our tremendous
benefactors along with Inco in providing
us with this with this wonderful
underground location it was housed in a
transparent sphere which is 12 meters in
diameter and about 5 centimeters thick
tremendous construction project to build
this and also to build the remainder of
the light sensor structure that looked
in at the heavy water in the central
region because we were restricted to
have everything in a mine cage which was
3 meters by 3 meters by 4 meters and so
this detector had to be very modular and
then reconstructed
on site so we looked in with these
lights this light sensor array at the
bursts of light that I just described to
you and we were very careful in terms of
radioactivity we surrounded everything
other than the heavy water sphere with
ultra pure light water and that was
housed in a watertight and radon gas
tight liner so we had graded
radioactivity you start with uranium and
thorium which is the main elements those
are the main elements that create
radioactive problems for us they're
about a part in a million in the rock
and in the middle it was less than about
a part in 10 to the 15 of those elements
so one radioactive decay per day per ton
of water so the people that developed
the radioactivity control systems led by
Dave Sinclair did a tremendous job to
make this project a success the location
is as I say 2 kilometers underground
it's down in a very active nickel mine
we traveled in this shaft and and
transported things to our site here a
very stable underground site which we
have used for for many years I guess I
should have had the Eiffel Tower on
there as the as the icon for this
particular presentation in the United
States I usually say that it's the
entire State Building that I should have
as the icon I have that on good
authority because one of my sons at age
7 when we were at Princeton went to the
New York City for a for a visit and came
back and told us that he had seen the
entire state building so we proceeded
from there
with this construction project you'll
see that everyone in this picture is
wearing lint-free clothing the
cleanliness aspect of this project was
tremendous well we had a million pieces
by
time we were finished we had less mine
dust on that entire structure then you
could pile on your thumbnail less than a
gram overall and that was essential for
us to be able to do this experiment we
estimated over 70,000 showers and
changes of clothing for people in order
to maintain that cleanliness throughout
the project the water systems were a
tremendous success
everything was very clean you can see
the example of the floors here and my
mother visited shortly after we got that
in place she said it looks pretty clean
there so I figured that was probably a
pretty good affirmative statement with
respect to how well we were doing you
can see here that we were posed with a
substantial problem when Stephen Hawking
visited but Inco was very good and
designed a special railcar to have him
come underground a very inspirational
figure this is the data that we obtained
from the first phase of the experiment
in which we were capturing the neutrons
in heavy water producing a six million
six point two five million electron volt
gamma ray and this is a distribution
I'll show you in a moment how we
calibrated that this is a distribution
that represented all neutrino types this
is what we expected from the charge
current reaction that was only electron
neutrinos and we did a test of this
which for which the results are shown in
the next transparency what we tested for
is a hypothesis that neutrinos were not
changing their type and what we found in
fact that what agreed with the data was
something that had less than a 5 Sigma
possibility of or less than one chance
in 10 million that in fact the trainer's
were not changing their type from this
data and the most consistent result had
a very good agreement between all of the
neutrinos after the change your type had
taken place
and the total number calculated by the
solar model John McCall and his group
and only one-third of the neutrinos were
actually still electron neutrinos
two-thirds of them had changed to the
other two type two types
when this result came out John Bacall
who had worked for so many years on this
was quoted as saying that he felt like
the DNA evidence for absolving him of
many years of questioning that finally
come in and so he was in fact a very
important part of this whole story of
solar neutrinos to show you how we were
able to know that those shapes were in
fact the way they would be we had a
source of 6.13 rather than 6.2 5 MeV
gamma rays that we were able to move
around within our detector with this
rather remarkable manipulation system
created by another one of our colleagues
and which enabled us to put a variety of
different radioactive sources and other
sources of gamma rays in particular this
one at almost any location in the
detector and this is what we expected
from the reaction that looked like that
were created by electron neutrinos and
these are calibration data that we
obtained with the other calibration
sources this is what we obtained with a
neutron source as well so we had the
ability to know what shapes we would
expect and we could do fitting to see
what it implied in terms of the physics
we also did a tremendous amount of work
to be sure that that question of whether
or not the numbers of gamma rays were
great enough to have produced free
neutrons simply from radioactivity that
they were low enough throughout the
experiment we had set a goal of how much
radioactivity we would have from radon
gas and they in the water from radium
and for
which is a daughter of thorium and
another radium daughter of uranium and
you can see that essentially starting
around the beginning of the project and
except for a few periods where we didn't
use the data we had met our goals
throughout the project this is making
measurements with external techniques on
the water system that we were using to
put to purify the water and we were also
able to look at the data inside the
detector itself and we had several
techniques for distinguishing between
well technique in terms of the isotropy
of the events for distinguishing between
uranium and thorium and we could set
limits on that basis as well we were
able to ensure that the numbers of
events that are arose from gamma rays
breaking apart deuterium were more than
a factor of three smaller than the
actual signal and we knew what that
number was to better than 30% giving us
an overall 10 percent uncertainty in the
initial phases and better later this is
the actual data that we obtained that I
showed you earlier and this is well
after we put salt in you can see that
what happened was that the charge
current result essentially stayed the
same and the result from the neutrons
capturing in the salt went up
substantially and what's interesting in
this slide is that this is what we
predicted this is what was simulated in
1987 by another one of my colleagues is
here today and you can see that the
relationship between these parts of the
data as you can see here and here and
what we predicted for the radiation
background wall which goes up strongly
in these two plots as well in the same
location is essentially the same in
other words that's what we said in 1987
would be possible if we could actually
do it and the data in later years shows
that it was actually done another way of
showing the results is to plot the
sensitivity of the reactions to muon and
tau neutrinos combined and electron
neutrinos on this axis this is a plot
associated with the
all neutrino sensitivity this is the
plot associated with just electron
neutrinos in that reaction you can see
where they cross is our result you can
also see that the results shown by the
black line here from doing the same plot
for the super-kamiokande data and then
with less accuracy our own data from the
electron scattering reaction is in very
good agreement with it you can see the
uncertainty in all neutrino types is
shown in this this number here and you
can see the comparison at about well
nearly 5 with the predictions with 5.8
plus or minus 1 point 3 from MacColl and
from silva and turk she has another very
substantial worker in that calculational
area that the agreement with solar
models is really very good and by the
time we got to the salt phase we had
more than 7 standard deviations clear
indication that the electron neutrinos
compared to all neutrino types is about
1/3 we then moved on to a phase in which
we installed 400 meters worth of very
low background Neutron detectors great
success by the Neutron detector team led
by Hamish Robertson but as an indication
of how you do go through some
difficulties in these experiments and
have to modify things mid-range you can
see what the what this the submarine
used to install them ended up looking
like this is what it looked like when we
first designed it I mean if you were
going to build a submarine what color
would you pick it of course
yellow submarine except that particular
yellow paint was very radioactive and we
had to scrub it all off and have a very
mundane submarine in order to do our
work so if you include the great work
that had been done by other measurements
including cameo Konda and super Kenya
Canada on solar neutrinos what you see
is that in 1980 now well here is the
first
all starting in 1968 of Ray Davis where
the threshold for using chlorine is at
this point and so everything in terms of
the different reactions as a function of
energy everything above this threshold
contributes to the results in 1989
kamiokande and super-kamiokande started
to provide results that were
increasingly accurate for the higher
energy neutrinos in 1992 the to gallium
experiments age and Galax /gn oh we're
sensitive to the PP neutrinos and in all
cases these were either exclusively or
predominantly sensitive to electron
neutrinos and so we still had a puzzle
in 2001 we started presenting our
results in 2000 before we presented our
results this is the sort of thing that
you would see for the results as a
function of energy different different
reactions in the Sun contributing to the
results and the theory being shown up
here as as a1 and you can see there were
deficits in all of the cases by the time
we had finished the three phases of the
of the project we had shown for all
three phases that the total number of
neutrinos was in very good agreement
with solar model theory and that the
electron neutrinos were actually four
boronate being observed at this sort of
level and it is this difference that we
use for that preliminary result I
mentioned with super-kamiokande so as
was mentioned neutrino oscillations are
a case where flavor change can occur in
an oscillatory fashion in quantum
mechanics that is usually represented as
the so-called flavor states where which
is the the state that's created when a
neutrino is produced either by an
electron reaction or a muon reaction or
a Tau reaction that they are a
superposition of states of mass 1 2 & &
and you can see what is now thought to
be an indication of what those
components are then as the neutrino
travels through space the mass fractions
change and then when you make a
measurement again to ask how much does
this look like an electron neutrino muon
neutrino or a town or Treena or in other
words in quantum mechanics what's the
probability that you would observe one
of those three types the fractions have
changed and so what you find in fact is
that for muon neutrinos you have that
changing over the distance of the of the
earth and in the case of the Sun you
also have a change it turns out that if
you combine all of those experiments
that I was mentioning and others that
have come later to measure solar
neutrinos you find that there's another
phenomenon that has occurred in the Sun
and phenomenon that was put forward by
mikheyev and Smirnoff working with
previous papers by wolfenstein in which
it is stated to be possible that if
there is a significant interaction
between the electron neutrinos as they
pass through the Sun with the electrons
the dense sea of electrons in the Sun
you could have a transition which would
be such that as it appears to be
occurring such that the electron
neutrinos get put into a pure mass to
state and stay in that state as they
travel from the Sun to the earth and
then end up in your detector showing up
roughly one one third electron neutrinos
and two thirds the other types that's a
representation of that mass to state in
addition to that what we determine with
these oscillation effects is the
difference in mass between the neutrinos
and we also determine this parameter for
the mixing which we refer to as theta
1/2
besides that we were able to determine
because of that in electron interaction
that mass 2 is actually greater than
mass 1 that's something that's referred
to as the hierarchy and for the case of
mass 3 relative to the rest it's
still an open question that may be
resolved we hope by some of these many
experiments that Professor Gadget
outlined for the future I'm going to
talk about a couple of other types of
experiments that we're going to be
pursuing for understanding neutrino
properties and also dark matter
particles in the future we now know that
neutrinos have too low a mass to be the
particles that may seem to make up the
dark matter in our universe five times
as frequent in our galaxy as the
particles that make us up and so we're
looking for other particles similar to
neutrinos but heavier referred to as
dark matter we've been very fortunate
that we've been able to expand the
laboratory and the vicinity of the snow
detector in Sudbury to create a new area
which has new experimental opportunities
we're also in the process of converting
the snow detector to a new detector
referred to as snow plus and so what you
see now is experiments in the case of
snow plus that will study something
called neutrino let's double beta decay
as well as further studies of solar
neutrinos and neutrinos from the earth
there are a number of experiments that
are studying dark matter and one that is
studying supernovae as will there's no
plus experiment the list of physics that
one is attempting to do with such
experiments in the case of neutrino las'
double beta decay we are converting the
snow experiment to a snow plus a
so-called experiment putting an organic
liquid that gives us a hundred times as
much light output having returned the
heavy water and by dissolving in that
tellurium compound we can use tellurium
as a potential for a potential
measurement of rare radioactivity
half-life not quite as long as proton
decay but a greater than 10 to the 25th
years or so so you've got to have a lot
more than 10 to the 25
nuclei in order to make a measurement of
that but we think with two tons we'll
have a good sensitivity if this rare
process called neutrinos double beta
decay occurs it means that neutrinos are
their own antiparticles and if so then
it's also sensitive to the absolute mass
which we would like to be able to
combine with the differences we've
measured to give the masses of all the
active neutrino types known and we have
the halo detector which reuses the snow
helium-3 detectors to along with lead as
a measurement of supernovae recycling is
a very big topic these days and we're
doing it as much as we possibly can in
these experiments there are also new
experiments in which we're attempting to
observe these dark matter particles
which are similar in their properties of
penetration and difficulty of detection
to neutrinos but which are significantly
more massive and there are a number of
experiments listed here which are taking
place in snow lab now I've emphasized
snow lab because that's where we are
working but there actually are many
laboratories around the world that are
doing similar experiments to this and
we're very optimistic that with the
progress that has been made in recent
years and and the excitement that has
been generated in this field that we
will have a much more complete
understanding of our universe for
example there are theories that suggest
that in fact neutrinos play a strong
role in the conversion of antimatter to
matter shortly after the Big Bang we we
have a very matter dominated universe
but it used to be roughly half and half
after these were created from pure
energy in the Big Bang and so that decay
process may be something that arises
from from a neutrino processes and some
combination of what's being measured
with the accelerator experiments and
possibility of understanding whether
they are their own antiparticles will be
significant in attempting to understand
those theories that some of the
highest energies that we can imagine
these are our sponsors and to whom we
are very grateful it emphasizes again
that although this experiment took place
in Canada it was a truly international
experiment from the very beginning as
you saw with herb Chen being one of the
founders and Dave Sinclair joining with
the UK very soon thereafter you see the
list of institutions that participated
in the project and here you see the 262
authors you can see that there are 262
author's although you may not be able to
read every name perhaps when this is put
on the web you can you can do that and
also 11 who have passed away since we
started this project I personally am
tremendously grateful to this
collaboration for all of the efforts
that they've made over the years and to
all of the spouses of the people in this
collaboration who are represented here
today as well so thank you to everyone
we thank her professor McDonald for this
wonderful talk and I would like to ask
both laureates to come on stage and I
think